the fear is with Summers as hot as this
followed by dry Winters we might see
that Taps running dry
so what are the potential Solutions
first idea pump more water from where
it's plentiful in these massive steel
pipes
to where it's scarce
and that's what they're trying here in
Lincolnshire with a run that goes all
the way from the Humber Estuary down to
Colchester
when these pipes are connected they'll
be capable of carrying 84 million liters
a day a total of 250 miles the ticket
price is half a billion pounds and there
is an environmental cost too it's very
energy and the hungry energy intensive
especially across a flat region like
ours we use a lot of pumps and pipes to
move water around and actually one of
the considerations we've made when we
were building this pipeline is how we
can make it the most energy efficient
and the least carbon hungry as possible
it is a massive project cutting through
fields and roads in a sweeping line
through East Anglia but the company
insists it's essential we know that if
we don't move water around our region
Taps will run dry and we're not talking
about in the next sort of 20 or 50 years
we're talking about in the next five
there's a water shortage across a large
part of England not just the southeast
have they got the water in the Humber
area to spare to send down to East Angus
yes that's the idea that the water is
more readily available and upon the
Humber bank and by building this
pipeline we can increase the resilience
right across the region you also pull
quite a lot of water out of the ground
in in abstraction is that going up or
staying the same what are the rules on
that so we've actually we're actually
lessening our abstraction
um in the amount of water we take out of
rivers but to the tune of about 84
million liters a year in you know in the
next five years and that's because we
will need to protect the environment and
actually this pipeline will allow us to
do that and we'll be able to actually
turn off some of our River and
groundwater abstraction points as a
result of moving water via this pipeline
around the region
this project is all about moving water
what about catching more rainwater in
the first place
in reservoirs like this one at Rutland
water the trouble is most of the ones
we've got around the country are running
low
so we're walking on what should be water
yeah so if the reservoir were full it
would be up here and you can see that
it's at the moment it's down here so
about 80 full a little bit lower than we
would expect at this time of year
because we've been going through a
period of dry weather so it's absolutely
critical that we do have these stores of
water I think I'm right this is one of
the last if not the last resource we
built in this area yeah so we haven't
developed reservoirs in this country at
this sort of scale since the 70s but we
are now looking at proposals for new
reservoirs and I'm working on reservoirs
in the anglian region we are proposing
two new reservoirs they're likely to be
cited in Lincolnshire and the fans each
one could cost one billion pounds
what we do know is that they are going
to take a long time to develop so
they're really long-term projects we're
working what does that mean when you say
long term so we're working on the early
proposals and early design work now for
water to be available at customer Taps
by the late 2030s so wow for nearly 20
years away time really long time
changing land to Lake is a very lengthy
costly business which is also likely to
upset some of the people who live there